قال المتحدث باسم هيئه الاركان
للقوات الاوكرانيه ان قوات بلاده تمكنت من
التقدم خلال الاسبوع الماضي في بلدات تقع
جنوبيه
وفي اتجاه بخموت اكد كفاليف تقدم القوات
الاوكرانيه بنحو 24 كيلو مترا مربعا اشيرا
الى ان احتدام القتال مع القوات الروسيه
التي لجات الى استقدام اذا احتدم هذا
القتال مع القوات الروسيه التي لجات الى
استقدام تعزيزات اضافيه
خلال الاسبوع الماضي ونتيجه للهجوم نحو
تقدمت القوات الاوكرانيه اكثر من كيلومتر
ليكون تقدمنا الاجمالي في هذه الاتجاهات
اكثر من ثمانيه كيلو مترات منذ بدايه
الهجوم حررنا اكثر من 10 كيلومترات مربعه
من الاراضي الاوكرانيه في الجنوب كما حررت
قواتنا اربعه كيلومترات مربعه في منطقه
بخموت وبشكل عام تبلغ المساحه المحرره في
اتجاهات باخموت 24 كيلومترا مربع